so we have to have a conversation today
that might be difficult for some in our
audience but it must be done because the
stakes are really high at this point
think back to 2016 before the November
of 2016 election you had people on the
Left who were saying things like you
know if it's Trump versus Hillary I'd
rather it be Trump really I'd rather it
be Bernie or Jill Stein or some other
so-called real leftist
but if it's Trump versus Hillary Hillary
will just reinforce the status quo Trump
will be so different
maybe wacky that he will totally shake
up the system and set the stage for a
real progressive in 2020 we have almost
four years now of a trump presidency and
it hasn't happened and it's another data
point that these ideas of acceleration
ISM haven't worked now I know you might
be thinking David you're wrong it's you
know we need eight years of Trump
instead of four for this to work or
David you're wrong Trump has shaken
things up such that we now will become
super progressive or something the
answer to those rebuttals is no and I'll
go through them one by one in a moment
but first we need to sort of understand
what we're talking about when we talk
about acceleration ISM there's narrow
acceleration ISM and then there's like
the broader colloquial use of the term
acceleration ISM so narrow acceleration
ISM if you if you look at the oranges or
origins of these ideas generally refers
to capitalism and socialism and the idea
is in order to get rid of capitalism you
accelerate it right you go to like uber
super ultimate extreme free-market
capitalism that will more quickly break
and then in will come radical change
socialism some other completely
different systems so in other words feed
capitalism so that it collapses now if
we say acceleration ISM more broadly
it's not so much about capitalism versus
socialism necessarily it's the idea of
accelerate the destruction of the
current system by putting in place
crazier and crazier leaders
that we speed up the system failing and
then being able to replace it with
something better some other people
characterize it as burn it down to
rebuild it properly so when some on the
Left said back in 2016 I'm a bernie
person so I'm like 98% on board with
Bernie's ideas you know maybe I'm 60% on
board with Hillary and I'm 10% on board
with Trump but I still want Trump
because Trump will violate norms and
violate conventions and do things that
will accelerate the total downfall of
the system and then we will usher in a
real era of true progressivism in 2020
so listen we've got four years of Trump
three and a half years so far it has
done very little for the progressive
movement in any real way we got Trump
the most lethally incompetent president
we've had in the modern political era
he's failed on everything right the
bogus tax reform plan the trade war
disaster with China he failed on
coronavirus he's failed on you know of
immigration he tried but failed to get
rid of the affordable care act but
certainly we've not made progress when
it comes to health care
he has failed failed failed while making
the United States a laughingstock and
what it led to
is a center-left Democratic nominee of
Joe Biden who may win or may not win so
despite those who in 2016 said Trump
will accelerate you know some kind of
progressive revolution and it's better
that he become president than Hillary
because she will essentially maintain
the status quo it didn't happen it
didn't happen so what do we have to do
to hold those folks accountable people
saying if it can't be a progressive that
meets my standards then I'd rather it be
Trump because his failures will usher in
progressivism well they haven't they've
ushered in being out of the Paris
climate Accords and falling further and
further behind on taking care of the
environment in the planet they've
ushered in a coronavirus response that
has completely failed and led to
unnecessary death they've ushered in tax
cuts that have completely failed to
actually improve circumstances and now
we just find ourselves with more damn
to undo if Joe Biden does win in
November and takes over in January he
simply has more damage to undo than what
we would have had Donald Trump lost in
November of 2016
so let's now deal with some of the
inevitable talking points here's one you
know what David four years of Trump
would have ushered in progressive change
if the DNC hadn't stolen the 2020
Democratic nomination from Bernie and
given it to Joe Biden come on guys come
on guys
Bernie lost by a lot before he dropped
out Bernie was already losing the
Democratic primary by a couple million
votes Bernie lost Super Tuesday and then
he lost Super Tuesday number two and
then he lost Super Tuesday number three
at that point we already were starting
to deal with coronavirus stay at home so
yes centrist candidates like P and Amy
got out of Biden's way but this doesn't
change that Bernie never had more than
mid to high 30s support period no matter
how many other candidates there were the
acceleration estar Gyu man's about that
inevitability were simply wrong and to
be perfectly frank how weak is your
argument that if four years of Trump was
going to bring in progressive change
inevitably
it simply failed because P and Amy got
out and that's why Bernie lost I think
that it's a very weak argument if it
could so easily be interfered with by
Pete and Amy ending their campaigns to
help Joe Biden now there's going to be
another argument which is Trump's
presidency will be acceleration estate
years of Trump instead of four right in
other words we were right in 2016 that
Trump instead of Hillary would usher in
progressive change through a burn it
down in order to rebuild it's sort of
perspective but four years isn't enough
we need a full eight years of Donald
Trump it's a full it's a completely post
hoc rationalization none of these folks
were saying back in 2016 Trump will
reinvigorate the progressive movement
but it'll take eight years instead of
four
they are having to say that now because
they were just wrong
in 2016 so we need another framework
Hillary Clinton was no progressive but
if Hillary Clinton were president our
coronavirus death toll would be lower it
wouldn't be zero but we have studies
from Columbia University and others if
we had a coordinated stay at home one
week earlier we could have avoided
30,000 of the hundred thousand deaths if
it had been two weeks earlier we might
have avoided fifty to sixty five
thousand of the hundred thousand deaths
that would have been different if
Hillary were president Hillary were
president we would still be in the Paris
climate agreement and we would not have
softened fuel emission standards we
would not have a ridiculous trade war
going on with China so let's really
understand that when people say now if
it's not Bernie
I'd rather another four years of Trump
why four years of Trump messed up so
many of our systems but those systems
aren't really any closer to going away
they're just messed up four years of
Trump damaged our planet more than it
had to and we can't get those four years
back four years of Trump didn't get us a
progressive nominee history tells us
that progress comes in modern political
systems like the one we have in the
United States progress comes in steps
now I've given these examples before but
they're important to repeat
you've got the Progressive Era of the
1890s to the 1920s
you've got the New Deal era officially
it's 1933 to 1939 some people consider
it to be a little bit bigger than that
you've got the civil rights era from the
end of the 1950s until you know into the
60s it's easy to look back now and say
wow look at that insane list of
accomplishments now with the benefit of
hindsight we see it but if you were in
the middle of the progressive era of the
late 1890s and it - early 1920s 30 years
is a long time if you're in the middle
of it it probably doesn't feel like such
significant change but when you look
back and you see wow the community
activism slowly eking out a better
Supreme Court a lot of the Progressive
Era reforms were upheld because we had
the right Supreme Court right to Supreme
Court justice
Evan Hughes justice Oliver Wendell
Holmes Herbert Hoover nominating Charles
Evan Hughes Teddy Roosevelt nominating
Oliver Wendell Holmes
it didn't seem like big progressive
change at the time but some of the
biggest advancements now that we now
take for granted during that era came
from exactly this type of incremental
ISM it's boring I know it but it's what
worked when you look at would trump get
to replace Ruth Bader Ginsburg or would
Biden get to replace Ruth Bader Ginsburg
if she retires that may not seem like
that big of a deal to some people but
history tells us that it is look then at
the New Deal era of the 30s under
Franklin Delano Roosevelt this came out
of the Great Depression it included
changes that now are considered to be
just fundamental parts of the fabric of
the country but they weren't burn it
down revolution things it was regulate
the banking industry programs to support
farmers the unemployed young people
elderly folks creating Social Security
which is huge of course you didn't get
that by burning down the system you
didn't get it by saying hey you know
what
instead of FDR because it can't be a
super progressive let's elect some right
wing nut no it didn't happen that way
history tells us
lastly the civil rights era right of the
50s into the 60s filled with protests
and sit-ins and rallies and a ton of the
day to day elements that we often see
today and and say today really would
need to be scaled up but a lot of the
progress was 1954 Brown versus the Board
of Education that was an early movement
an early moment in the civil rights era
and it was a decision made by the
Supreme Court reinforcing the importance
of who gets to pick the justices is it
Trump or is it Biden 1956 and
double-a-c-p works within the judiciary
to win desegregation of the bus system
57 Martin Luther King creates the SCLC
to support local protest movements
you've got the new North Carolina
drugstore sit-in in 1960 which sparks
more sit-ins these were not burn it down
acceleration Asteras of progress that
took a while that were incremental and
we've wasted four years with Donald
Trump we've wasted four years where some
progress could have been made and you
now would have to redirect the ship so
to speak less so then it will have to be
redirected when Donald Trump eventually
leaves we have a choice there's no
reason to make the same mistake again in
November people's lives are riding on it
and we need to understand the same
argument that's being made now about
listen if it's bite and give Trump
another four years people made that
argument in 2015-2016 it failed it
failed look at what happened there is no
empirical case for saying well another
four years will finally fix it it's not
how the system is designed it's not
what's going to happen if you disagree
let me know I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
and I welcome your comments also
remember to sign up for the David Pakman
show audio podcasts a lot of you that
watch our clips on YouTube may not know
we've got an audio podcast free every
day get it on iTunes stitcher google
play podcasts our website it's
everywhere and it is one of the more
popular ways to consume the show every
day quick break right back after this